man: The Google Play
Developer Console
lets you publish your apps
and games on Google Play
to over 1 billion Android users
around the world.
The Developer Console
is full of features
that can help you grow your app
or game business.
We've chosen ten tips you can
take advantage of right now.
Improve your app quality
by getting feedback
from trusted users before
you launch to the world.
How?
Follow the instructions
from the APK tab
and invite users through
an open or closed beta.
They'll be able to download the
test app from the Play store,
and you can start getting
feedback on your new features.
Don't let hiccups trip you up
or slow you down.
Staggering updates
lets you release your app
to progressively more people,
so you can catch and fix
any glitches
before they have a chance
to affect a wider audience.
With store listing experiments,
you can test up to three
variants of your app icon,
text, and graphics
on your store listing
to see which gets users
downloading your app.
Take a data driven approach
to optimizing our store listing
and try new things.
Don't just assume
it's good enough.
Ratings and reviews will tell
you what your users love
and love less about your app,
and replying to reviews
creates dialogue,
which builds loyalty.
The Developer Console monitors
your app's performance
in Google Play and suggests
optimization tips
and provides a handy guide
to utilize each suggestion.
App indexing lets users open
your app's content
directly from Google searches
on their devices.
It's a great way to reengage
users who've installed your app
and help them rediscover
your app's features.
Once you've added app indexing
to your app,
verifying your website
in the Developer Console
to start taking advantage of
the additional app engagement.
Gain actionable insights on how
users are interacting
with your app by linking
your Google Analytics account
to the Developer Console.
You'll see additional reports
on new and active users,
plus new metrics like
the Google Play Referral Flow
to help you understand how users
are discovering your apps.
Sudden drops in your installs
or ratings?
Are there more crashes
than usual?
Email alerts will alert you
so you can be totally on top
of your app's performance
and minimize a bad user
experience.
Gain deeper insight into
the behavior
of your app and its users
by exporting your most important
stats:
installs, upgrades, reviews,
ratings, crashes.
Analyzing this data in detail
lets you spot trends
and then focus on the
improvements most important
to your users.
Make app publishing
and management tasks
easy, time efficient,
and useful
by automating them.
Push out a daily update
to your alpha testers.
Update localized store listing
text and imagines.
Add or delete in-app products
to keep your app super fresh.
Head over to the Google Play
Developer Console
to start taking advantage
of these features.
If you want more tips on how
to improve your app
or game's performance and build
a better app business,
check out the other videos
in this series
and download "The Secrets to
App Success" on Google Play.